The Joe Rogan Experience yeah you got
that guy Keith you got Lucas there's a
lot of good guys yeah yeah a lot of good
women there a lot of good there's a
couple non-barners yeah we got at least
one
checking on the box it's a diverse group
we gave him his own Bud Light after the
first week we put his face on a can
do you have any beer yeah you want a
beer I take a light up here let's get
some Bud Lights Let's uh do this yeah in
support of Bud Light in their time let's
be allies by getting a little distracted
we're going to be allies yeah you know
because Kid Rock and Travis Tritt have
put the [__] hammer down I know
they're really [__] fighting the good
fight man here's my take okay
oh
like what you're do what you're doing
what they're doing is just spreading the
brand to uh an extra group of people
yeah why if something is good do you
give a [__] who's got it
like will we do this with cheesecake
like you know what I'm saying like if
there was like a bomb ass cheesecake and
all of a sudden you know some radical
group like antifa really got in the
cheesecake could be like [__] this yeah
and if the like if the Cheesecake
Factory scent antifa cheesecake you know
for 10 more years of Chaos
celebratory yeah if only Isis had bear
claw Donuts yeah I'm still eating those
but on the other hand I loved Kid Rock's
video because I love that I love Cheers
Cheers man I love that kind of thinking
not even that I agree with it
I like wild people yeah I like raising
hell man I like to do to take some
machine gun to a stack of Bud Lights
it's like [__] Anheuser bush
this will show up but I mean where's he
gonna go now you're gonna go to Coors
don't they all support like uh LBGTQ
plus AI whatever the hell else they're
at attaching to IT issues they all do I
mean I'm from Colorado and Coors has had
those rainbow cans forever [__] Shane
Gillis is heartbroken I was with it I
was opening for him last weekend this is
what sucks
he drinks Bud Light every time he does
protect our Parks those things have
[__] millions of views I know where's
his can of beer he did not he was not he
said the exact same thing he's
problematic oh yeah he's an issue man
he's an issue being one of the funniest
[__] human beings alive on planet
Earth and also generous and Community
great guy yeah but for whatever reason
they won't give him a Bud Light they
should give him some lips if they were
smart
they would send Shane a Bud Light with
his face on it too and say we love
everybody well kan's not big enough to
fit his face
that's true it's a big round hat you
could put like half of his face yeah
like you know like a like an artsy thing
right yeah they put them all together
yeah there you go whoa did you get a
left side of the face or the right side
Bud Light sponsors the moon so if you're
too fisting yeah you know mm-hmm no man
I think that uh it's crazy when people
get upset about that stuff because the
people who get upset about that stuff
value Liberty and freedom so much and
they want to live their lives undeterred
by anyone's rules but they think that
the company that they like is giving in
to the woke agenda that's what it is
there's no woke agenda well they think
there is in like uh movies and
television and media and commercials I
was allegedly conceived on zemas yeah
that's the way to go yeah have your kid
on a delicious fruity sort of uh bubbly
soda-like alcoholic Mom and Dad split a
[__] 24 pack of Zima and made me in
Glenwood Springs wasn't too strong no
you know okay though dude did it you
can't have like eight of them
I've never had eight zemas I have you've
had eight yeah because they brought them
back you know sema's a thing with I'm
not really trying to get drunk you know
like if I'm trying to get drunk I'm
drinking whiskey if I'm drinking I'm
typically trying to get drunk always
yeah don't you just like to have a
little buzz I'll have a little glass of
wine here and there there you go yeah
Zima drinks returning to Summer of 2018
for a limited time yeah I'm gonna try to
bring it back hey bro bring it back come
on Zemo I'm on your side yeah I liked it
I like them I get it yeah I don't get it
[__] white claws made it but zemas
didn't well these are all sugar though
but tell me tell me how the [__] white
claws made it and Zima did it as a
timing thing is it like betamax and the
VHS tape the superior product doesn't
make it well Zima had like 20 years head
start on white cloth bro I used to get
so much [__] for ordering zema they're
like what are you doing bro well were
you at the pool hall no I have a [__]
improv on Melrose it's on your right in
front of me yeah Comics are making fun
of me for drinking Zima I'm like I'm
sorry it's delicious it looks like a
potato
what do I need to know is it bad for you
and what are the fun facts about Zima
there's no fun facts The Branding sucks
this zema's like Blockbuster videos like
no one thought it was gonna go away but
here we are in a post zema world it's
over
it's weird because it was delicious it
didn't taste bad at all it's not a bad
product it was kind of viscous though
um
we had that kind of Milky look to it
when it was in the bottle for too long
really yeah I thought it was like Sprite
it started clear but then if you had it
on the shelf for a while how long did
you leave your Zim on a show I remember
my I think my dad had like a couple
zemas in his office a little milky milk
yeah look at that yeah but that's just
the skim milk CGI image
that's what it looks like it looks like
[__] soda
it's a bottle of malt delicious clear
malt soda I'd be more surprised if you
had zema in here than that you have mad
honey
you probably have to get it on eBay from
your dad yeah
my dad takes the helicopter yeah your
dad's got some cases but the things like
about this dilemma Mulvaney thing it's
like it's just someone who wants a lot
of attention and you're giving that
someone a lot of attention and you're
trying to reach another audience like
I I saw and I was like what the [__] is
this my initial reaction is like this is
silly transparent but it's also your
um Bud Light fan your typical Bud Light
fan is like NASCAR [__] sports like
that's most of the people that are
drinking Bud Light guys like Shane most
people if I you saw the Bud Light
demographics yeah of who's drinking Bud
Light bigots
guy's like [__]
his choking shame
yeah yeah sure thank you
um [__] I lost it you were talking about
oh yeah just how uh the Target
demographic of Bud Light but it's like a
lot of companies are using this person
there's more than one company there's
like a bunch of them like Nike and a
bunch of other stuff also she's pretty I
get it no I mean I see nothing wrong
good luck hey man
yeah it's it's one of those things it's
like it's funny what people get like
super outraged about
you know like we're in the middle of uh
you know Tulsi gabbard posted up some
stuff the other day
um about the restrict act and uh you
flip the top here I showed you before
pull the top back there you go thank you
well I did it before you before that's
like one of those teaching man to fish
things yeah it's not going to be lit you
know I know yeah I gotta get rid of that
you know like no one's freaking out
about that but they're freaking out
about Bud Light like how you how is that
the big deal
I think it's goofy because I think that
person's goofy but if you want to hire a
goofy person like who gives a [__] it's
kind of hilarious when someone says 365
days of Womanhood it was also on April
Fool's Day that's true too but it also
was just a can with that person's face
on it yeah that's all it was it was a it
wasn't like something they were selling
yeah they didn't have it in stores no
it's kind of funny yeah I like that
people get mad I thought what Kid Rock
did was funny
I laughed at it I told him I thought it
was funny and but I also
it doesn't make me mad not at all it
just makes me like what what I just like
I get what they're doing though they're
trying to get people that are popular
they're just looking for influencers to
help them and they're trying to look
more inclusive because of the uh you
know assumptions people make about Bud
Light drinkers but those assumptions and
also look at us we're on the biggest
platform in the world discussing Bud
Light for like 10 minutes right it's
gonna work for the brand too yeah for
sure yeah Shane loves it I like Miller
Lite more I like Sam Adams I like a dark
beer oh I want to be where I can have
like 17. oh really yeah I want to be
sipping beer all night